something is here killing us it's a
terrible thing watch people die of
cancer and realize the suffering that
and to realize that you could be next
welcome to reserved Louisiana this is
the cancer capital of the United States
but we know that people in this little
town is suffering at a cancer rate
that's seven to eight hundred times that
of the nation we're in what's known as
cancer alley in Louisiana an area
between New Orleans and Baton Rouge
lined with petrochemical plants and
refineries most of the towns here are
poor and black with extremely high rates
of sickness and suffering
Robert Taylor has lived here all his
life and he's surprised he's made it to
the age of 77 my mother got cancer my
brother died of lung cancer my sister's
son died of lung cancer my wife got my
daughter when it wasn't close relatives
it was a next-door neighbor he's
currently in a legal battle against a
large chemical plant a few blocks from
his house it's the only plant in the US
which makes chloroprene a chemical the
EPA says is a likely carcinogen I think
the ignitions need to stop I don't think
that human life should be subject to a
profit motive what chloroprene goes to
make is the neoprene material that goes
in wetsuits and laptop covers it's more
of a product that's made for people's
recreation well that's a that's a part
of that humiliation have we suffered we
don't even have a swimming pool in a
black community the predatory attitude
that the powers that be half talk black
people has not changed in sleep or the
methodologies but not changed but an
affecting all of us is still asleep
we're still deep in slavery
in America Reserve was once a thriving
black community post-world War two
Roberts parents and many others were
drawn to work in the large sugar
refinery or farming the surrounding
sugarcane fields the Sugar Company
closed in 1985 and now petrochemical
companies have bought out much of the
town because of its proximity to the
Mississippi River highways and railroads
all that's left of Roberts childhood
neighborhood now is this cemetery which
is ironically filled with Roberts
relatives who mostly died of cancers
linked to the emissions all our
ancestors here now covered by this
monstrosity here I need a visit from
here I can't go on that property without
I can't even walk across now to go into
the cemetery this is the cemetery across
the tracks this is where I was standing
with Robert petrochemical companies on
all of the surrounding land my mom and
my dad in their brothers and sisters
uncles and aunts my grandfather but how
do I what look what I've got to go
through look what I'm up against
just trying to come
visit with Robert teamed up with Wilma
subra a chemist who is doing pro bono
scientific analysis for the community
they hold regular meetings to fill the
town in on what's going on everyone's
been exposed for a very very long time
DuPont has been making chlorine here in
La Paz reserve area for 49 years and
releasing it into the air DuPont
operated the plant until Dinka took it
over in 2015 keeping on almost all of
the facilities employees this is the
only community exposed to chlorine at
these high concentrations in the whole
United States chlorine is released into
the air during its production process it
can't be seen but does give off a
pungent smell the chemical enters the
body when it's breathed in ingested or
absorbed through the skin and is linked
to liver kidney and digestive cancers as
well as leukemia hurt and reproductive
problems it's in your opinion is it
undeniable that it's linked yes it is
totally undeniable that the link is
there I guess we have the fifth Ward
school right there with the lower
elementary being really really exposed
this school is a big point of contention
Robert went to school here in the late
50s early 60s during segregation it's
still a majority-black school today the
school has levels of chlorine that are
400 times higher than what the EPA says
is safe to breathe a large percentage of
these students live right here as well
so they're being bought these kids are
being reported with that some of them 24
hours a day how far away is this
Elementary School from the plant 1,500
feet so yeah right yes right beyond
those trees those trees right there is
the plan people most affected by the
negative aspects of it or a poor and the
powerless which in America by and for
the people of color all black people
when what I get forms from them since
I've been involved it's just a sense of
helplessness powerlessness how can we
fight these for rich organizations once
we can get enough people to join with us
that's where our power will be you know
will exercise political power that's
where our hope lies in
[Music]
you